the first flight carrying asylum seekers
to rwanda is expected to leave the uk
today the controversial plan aims to
discourage people from illegally
crossing the english channel into
britain human rights groups say some of
those scheduled to be deported include
people fleeing afghanistan and syria as
well as iran and iraq seven people
currently remain on the passenger list
after dozens were removed following
legal challenges in this case
for more on that let's cross over to our
correspondent bigoted mars in london
bigoted what's the current status of
this plane will it take off today
yes foreign secretary british foreign
secretary liz truss has confirmed that
the flight will take off at some point
today even though there are really not a
lot of asylum seekers on board so the
home office had originally not given any
concrete figures but it had been
reported that they were trying to deport
almost 40 people so now the figure much
much lower but foreign secretary list
trust uh is saying that it is justified
that the flight should go just to
establish the principle that asylum
seekers that come via the english
channel on boats that they cannot expect
to have their claims processed here but
they can expect to be deported to rwanda
so
around 40 originally planned uh only
seven will remain on that plane uh
that's because of an intense legal
battle what were the most important
points there
there were several legal battle battles
um gerhard there was a coalition uh
there still is a coalition of of
charities and unions and they are still
fighting uh in front of the british
courts they're saying that this is
just generally the principle is not
right they're saying this doesn't comply
with the human rights act and also
they're arguing that rwanda is not a
safe that country and then there are
also individual battles on behalf of
asylum seekers and as we know some have
been successful because there are no a
lot less people on the flight than
originally intended
now how is this practice being viewed by
the british public are there any polls
about this
there has been a lot of criticism um
publicly there has been there have been
church leaders and they have said that
this is an immoral practice
that shames britain there is a petition
going on and if you look at the website
the sort of numbers are increasing by
the minute over 150 000 people have put
their signatures down in order to stop
this practice there are celebrities they
are petitioning the airlines and arguing
uh urging the airlines not to not to
help with this practice what unites all
these people is that they argue that
this is something that is just morally
wrong and uh for example the opposition
uh is saying the labor opposition saying
it's it's something that's unbritish
however the government is arguing that
it's justified they say what's morally
wrong are the people smugglers who are
taking people in a very dangerous way
are helping them across the english
channel and for them this is their main
goal to stop this practice
so remind us again these people are
being removed to rwanda why rwanda
so the british government has struck a
deal with the government of rwanda they
regard ronda as a safe third country and
the iranian government has agreed to
take on uh the claims of of these people
who are seeking asylum in the uk and if
they are successful they can uh stay in
rwanda for for up to five years so
basically it's transporting people who
originally wanted to come to the uk most
of them um have some sort of ties to the
uk have family here this is why they
went on this dangerous journey across
the channel but now instead of having
their claims processed in the uk they
can face this deportation to rwanda
thank you very much uw correspondent
bigot master in london thanks
you